[Music]
my name is Ada strablov and I'm a
professor at the Stanford Graduate
School of Business as well as the
founder and director of our Venture
Capital initiative unless you know where
to look you might not see it but Venture
Capital saw VCS are probably having a
major impact on your life every single
day
VCS are people who invest in small risky
high growth startups and they often
invest in companies that are trying to
change our world think about Google
Microsoft Facebook Zoom many other Tech
Giants they were all funded by VCS back
when they were very small companies
my team and I attract the successful
kovid vaccines and found that about half
are delivered by companies supported by
venge capital
and even though it's in the news a lot
more during Tech booms this powerful
sector of the economy predates the
internet my research shows that since
the 1970s the VC industry is behind
about a third of all large barbecue
trade companies created in the United
States
so how do these influential people
choose what ideas to fund
even many company Founders seeking bench
Capital Money don't really seem to
understand the VC mindset as I could
that's what my research set out to
domestify my team and I found that the
most important stage is what's referred
to as deal selection
dual selection is after they've already
identified a startup to consider but
before this is decide whether to invest
in it or not to invest during the deal
selection process VCS put every
potential investment through something
they call the deal funnel on average a
100 startups go into the deal final and
only one comes out meaning that VC is
invest in about one startup for each
hundred that they consider
the first part of the funnel is
typically where we see is evaluate the
business model and the setup idea often
misses will say well the market is
obviously too small so therefore we
don't have any interest
if the setup passes that stage then VCS
will typically meet with the founding
team to evaluate them again often enough
VCS will say well the business is
interesting but why not impressed by the
founding team that's another startup
squeezed out of the narrowing funnel at
the next stage which relatively few
deals reach they'll bring the startup to
their partners
and then the partners will decide to
proceed with a very careful due
diligence on only some of the deals
on average this entire process takes
almost three months and it's highly
selective
what we found was that the median bench
Capital firm considers about 400 deals a
year and only invests in four
the Highland selective process benefits
us all down the line for example
my research shows that without Venture
capitalists companies like Zoom might
not have been identified created funded
or scaled up and of course had Zoom not
existed our experience during the covet
pandemic would have been quite different
this is rigorous decision making process
can increase the success rate of
companies that change our lives so how
can a business idea make it through the
deal funnel my team and I talked to
almost 900 venge capitalists at over 700
firms asking these questions many of
those for the first time
we found that in order to try and
minimize risk VCS tend to concentrate on
what I call the jockey rather than the
horse
the jockey is the founders and the early
management team of a company in other
words the human element the human
capital
the course is everything else the
product business model Market technology
most VCS will not invest unless they
have complete trust in that early
management team that they can execute on
the idea even with the best course this
is figure that without a good jockey to
ride it it will not be winning the race
putting together those hundreds of
servers and conversations with vanish
capitalists we started to get a clearer
picture of who they are and who they
aren't
it turns out that the VC mindset is very
different from other Financial investors
they consider many more opportunities to
start with other investors will not have
as wide deal funnel as venge capitalists
this is also much more ready to take on
risks and they are much more likely to
co-invest with other venge capitalists
so they're a part of a larger ecosystem
because of all these differences VCS
have to come up with their own Financial
strategies because the standard
Financial models like the ones we teach
are MBA students here at Stanford aren't
really applicable that much to early
stage companies
Concepts like net present value or
discounted cash flow techniques just
aren't that much in use since you can't
predict future cash flows of an idea or
forecast Revenue without reliable data
and the data for these startups just
doesn't exist yet
so if you are not investing
in startups how does this all relate to
you
[Music]
a little bit more like VCS
for example
people tend to be extremely risk-averse
so uh corporate decision makers
and when you invest that actually might
not be a bad idea
but when you are trying something new
either new personal or professional life
being willing to fail and staying
flexible is beneficial that's what the
VC mindset is all about
VCS have a lot to teach us about doing
plenty of research before making
decisions but also experimenting and
keeping an open mind that's how you've
been big in business and the same is
true in life
[Music]
thank you